in his mind
is he sitting there like hey i was doing
this for my dad i was doing this for my
legacy i was doing this for my mother
russia i was doing this for this
who is his loyalty to is it is he
worried about the people around him that
are upset with them that he may lose
power there's somebody that wants to
replace him because he's 69 years old
right now is he thinking that
his loyalty is is to himself first of
all secondly i want to add a feature
here
uh when you you had zilinski's picture
up there
he doesn't look like a
strong individual physically
putin has a black belt in karate
putin has
cultivated an image of being a real
tough guy
uh you you know that infamous picture of
him riding a horse
no shirt on no sure
and
for quite some time i think he stopped
doing as he got too old he would have
participated in a hawk in a hockey game
annual hockey game where he and four
others took on the starting five of the
national team yeah and putin always
scored the goals
right he always had a hat trick against
the best players in the world exactly so
right so ridiculous
this this is so ridiculous but he
believes that he can pull it off and he
actually seems to be pulling it off
because i have a video of one of the
games and you know he scored a goal in
the first 20 seconds and everybody
screams yeah
so so that's that's kind of like when
you let the little kid run down the
football field and all the yeah the
tacklers move out of the way and the
six-year-old scores a touchdown i mean
that's essentially what he's doing it's
propaganda so so he has created that
image of himself as a strong man and he
believes in it
because you know if
well more importantly than he believes
in it the russian people believe in it
yes how do they fall for the propaganda
propaganda
time and time again especially with him
well
and
i i've been lately uh watching quite a
few documentaries about uh
you know how hitler came to power and
how he
uh he ran the third reich
how did the germans believe all that
nonsense how would they all go like this
in unison
uh
and and and and that was an
educated populace do you think putin is
an extremely sensitive guy
yes and i tell you he's hypersensitive
okay so
you know why i'm asking that
i think you know where i'm going with
this do you think he's super
hypersensitive yes and i tell you why i
know this um
and there's a there's a fellow by the
name of olek kalugan
uh he was uh kgb he was in charge of uh
counterintelligence uh for the first
directorate first directorate was
espionage i was in the first directorate
uh and uh at one time he was
vladimir's boss
and i met olek a couple of times he
lives in the united states he's a
citizen
and uh
he
said you know
he wasn't he wasn't much of a good agent
but there's he said there's one thing i
will not do
he i will not say anything i will not
attack him personally
apparently he may know something that
would uh
be putin's on doing
talk talking about sensitivity and i'm
not gonna
mention that on on air so there were
some hints but
there
apparently it's a great great
sensitivity because of that ego the
narcissism right
and uh there has to be there has to be
something that to be at that level you
have to be hyper sensitive about
something and and and running around uh
you know american politicians and
calling them all kinds of names is is
not necessarily doing us any good and it
could just i don't i don't disagree make
it more crazy i don't disagree yeah i
don't know why do you ask that question
what were you hypersensitive yeah oh all
i'm saying is if you're dealing with
somebody hypersensitive you have to
the ability to tame yeah is is is a is a
political uh
skill like he's got they got
yeah
so the more sensitive he is the more
dangerous he is to the world and i think
he's very sensitive i think he's
extremely hyper-sensitive so i think
whoever makes the next moves with them
they have to make it the right way by
the way props to zielinski for not
attacking back in
doing any of that he's he's saying
listen man i'm not i'm just fighting you
back but i'm not hurting you yeah
they're taking the soldiers and they're
holding the soldiers and the soldiers
are apologizing they're making a video i
don't know if you've seen those videos
where the soldiers who ukraine takes
from russia russians and they're
prisoners of war they're saying on video
man i'm sorry i'm just doing my job
they're just telling me what to do
there's hundreds of these
by the way no no no not propaganda
actual russian soldiers no meaning
that's what they're using to win the
hearts and minds of other people yeah so
so what is it is it fear do you fear it
are you worried what could happen are
you worried what he's going to do and so
you said something he said his loyalty
is only to himself
i don't know if i i i
believe that i think i think it is to
himself but i think it's
it's is it a lenin is it a stalin is it
a
there's got to be something more than
that and to be able to handle this guy
you got to do it in a very it's too late
the strategy of trump doesn't work with
biden right now you can't go from not
being a tough guy to being a tough guy
yeah like remember when ted cruz and
marco rubio all of a sudden started
talking trash to trump yeah it didn't
work and everybody's like what the hell
are you doing that's not your identity
stop it you look funny you're not a
troll trump's a troll you're not a troll
yeah don't try to play in the mud
for his entire life he's a pro he comes
from the streets of new york he's a
tough guy you're not a tough what are
you doing ted what are you doing so did
a lot of good luck so bike cannot play
the card of trump trump's been that he's
i don't think he's trying to though no
he's not he's not trying so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]
you